right now yeah how do you feel talking
that tens of viewers right now I feel I
feel like I'm not quite ready I forgot
to shave this morning so much five
o'clock shadow it's coming but that's
okay that's what's beautiful about is
that's the real you
it is it is the real me no I'm not the
real me is a disgusting fat neckbeard
[ __ ] you think you're fat I don't think
I'm fat what do the neckbeard definitely
does add weight to the face it makes you
look more tested testicular or just
stick euler do why is that what I'm
going weakly and maybe I mean I guess
and this being racist to white people
you think all white people look like
testicles I think they do you won't look
like dim sum so what does dim sum look
like dim sum look like yeah I never had
to have some I've never had like
dumpling you just make you [ __ ] up now
mine was that Lee's accurate wasn't it
maybe it's just cuz your head is round
it is that runs it that's I okay so like
my face from like
is my mom and then this is my dad yeah
that's my dad I got the idea from my dad
the nicely shaped face from my mom
that's great
together I have the perfect nose so
you've got a little bit of your dad a
little bit of your mom
the court jester that they don't act the
both looks the same
yeah it's a very progressive
so this is we're exploring New York yes
right okay welcome well thank you yeah
okay well I've I've been living here for
a while now it'll be five years in
August actually so you're like a pro
I've only been here two years
right yeah so I yeah I've had everything
happen I've been shot on in fiber and in
front of its new store before there's a
Disney Store here yeah Times Square no
it's all right by the M&M store I think
I have not had that happen to me I've
been I haven't been like robbed per se
like her say yeah I've definitely liked
drunkenly given all the money in my
wallet to a homeless and then he like
rudely and selfishly demanded that I go
to an ATM and take out more
well this homeless before they don't
have any self-control now I know they
probably deserve it no just kidding you
know because why do we produce more
homeless people in America than any
other what do we produce more homeless
people in America more than any other
country in the world that's real I mean
more than average is that true yeah
undoubtedly and I feel like China
definitely has more most people just
because of like
but they they have like food stamps
[Music]
so we want to be
[Music]
it's really more
the honestly
[Music]
National Express all the way the super
epic a verdict we included is V Jackson
- Emily literally any thickness
koreatown authentic babies men against
the flushing
I actually just went to Flushing from
her style
yeah yes right
yeah yeah it's like a child like a
little less dense Chinatown
I had yo
right
like
where
it's an emergency
if you're directed by us
definitely got a nice flavor
Asian flavor injection
you have yeah it's like authentic until
you see the places
authentically is immaculate
hey I've been told by two people that
Italians
my sister 23
yeah exactly yeah and they can float her
like sell their DNA
Oh that'd be attractive
say don't like like blood in the bedroom
yeah that's what is definitely like very
cool
yeah
well that's right I'll take light
fire
you pass out of the side of life and
it's um
I think you're just being closed-minded
to alternate forms of
and maybe should be more open-minded me
but I think that your conception of
yourself is such that you can't imagine
moving your elbow in that way and if you
do you would break your arm so it's a
safety net body is like just an
inconvenience and transfer your head
around sometime yeah they definitely do
you feel like a disconnect between my
head and my body ever sure me too
yeah I wish more people were like that
because the body of the past and ahead
of the future
[Music]
it's just like common sense like you can
either get really good at being an
animal or really good at being a human I
think we want to be in the back of this
[Music]
oh my god
seven minutes fellas
new terminology yeah it's like middle
package
[Music]
anyway
a couple elevators randomly
what people
it'd be tight I think we get annoyed by
the
[Music]
not like this particular one
as I go up this
Gregory
so I don't ever want to
they're forced to learn about matches in
Catholic school
everything why would you learn about fat
rides aren't they all about late Jesus
like different universes like over Imagi
io they had bad rise in the Bible
like mystical beings
[Music]
well word see the folks supported
and like we just we only read books I
feel like we need to follow this group
they're very charismatic I know they're
wow I mean I didn't have to say that
part that maiden kind of weird I think
they are young scholars out on the town
just learning and churning and burning
and we should not objectify them
adjusting the kerning newsletter
I just wanted an excuse to say turning
turning is the distance of three letters
yes
Vega does the
more stable than my mental state you
know it's funny I think I might have
recorded like my Iran
but I had this thing in sir
blessing her I
[Music]
No
over there
I'm so practical
[Music]
I would care about practicality
daughter oh [ __ ]
secretly jealous
because like if you have a selfie stick
it's one thing
but I feel like the selfie stick kind of
adds like a officiality oh for sure for
sure people what are you filming can I
be on it yeah we have like a legit
microphone even if it wasn't plugged
into anything just like if we had one
people would be coming at us election
right they would want to please to this
the best they've hand us their resumes
with the full-color headshot that they
carry around with them all the time yeah
even though they don't have like a
backpack or anything they literally just
looking with it out of their hands
that's
like a conscious decision to make
something a product that one here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like anything that ends in huge
like a cabbage you know
because I like a queue noise
huge
exactly something with a heart
[Music]
every 10 days he stopped eating position
of GMOs America they got
service possible I'd rather have one
patient
[ __ ] that's not you see that in full
style project what do you like so much
everything
I mean I heard a very thick brush is the
way already started please email a
bigger Thank You Alberto Manny got mine
an accelerator died
we can attract place without his
all-star band
speakers something they were happy in
shipping the grocery story
milk thanks free
because their economy is like in the
toilet and
that all it means to be
before they don't develop a I guess
economically
yeah
because they're not like us where it's
like
they think everything
[Music]
yeah
transfer under whether we do it sedation
as a university and compute and arm or
we should just get three our lunch
breaks I think that's a good starting
go drink wine and have sex
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're happy
yeah
what you don't want the bedroom
exactly strictly a sexual oddity yes
yeah look for the element platform is
fine blood on the dance floor fine
what in the bedroom
the line man it shows that something has
gone wrong of whatever it is you're
doing
just like the Democrats uh too
controversial
what are they accusing Republicans of
doing that they're doing
being racist mainly so whatever being
racist to whites and well they know
because it's not no I'm a professor
being racist to minorities yeah they're
just subtle about it they they're subtle
about it think of so out of their way to
prove that they're like holier than thou
that they end up infantile izing these
people these are like I like I just did
by saying BT people they're not even
real people so they they make them a
cartoon character
they're not real so they can infantilize
them
but Republicans do the same thing
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
they're just working for cities
or an something
legacy when I was like in high school I
moved here I was like well you can get
Chinese credit for I am
in Chinese
that's very young
it's crazy like I've had with like a lot
of like spreads and over my age people
we can't party any
it was like
I think that we exaggerated our partying
in college
yeah I feel insecure for knowing
yeah
we are
[Music]
this now where do you just post the
entire hey what's there to edit all of
it is gold so far it's not cold or it is
that I was on the right side of the
right stairs and that guy didn't take my
space I mean when will people start
respecting me
my vigor society is sick and everyone is
unhappy because we are being used as
fuel for capitalism and it's funny
things like in Europe like people like
our it's all like yeah we can't even
drink in public
like we're keep on some people say oh
we're so backwards because we don't have
the universal basic income
we don't have universal health care
hello let's start small start small
legalize drinking in public folks I know
that's okay I will
yeah I will whoever gets on that back my
one friend the one I was talking about
earlier in my own
she would say she says that is why we
need to take away white woman's right to
vote why because she you give them the
right to vote first thing they do is ban
alcohol
oh I mean that wasn't a good move right
they were just trying to cut down on
right then there's a little panicky but
actually I made it worse gave rise to
the Mafia and that's what's happening
with our illegal drug game yeah
war
in Mexico we just don't feel it so we
can keep doing it because they don't
feel the impact of it oh my god come on
man
so we live what are you saying illegal
drugs women vote yes and we should know
America sucks
people in Europe want to live here yeah
so they have
so what is it what is that American Miss
that they miss out on that our viewers
are probably
but it might carry through its
like
I felt like
people were like [ __ ] their [ __ ]
pants in Italy oh yeah
this is like a small town man I think
what's great about America is that there
are no rules there are rules but the
appearance of that there are no rules
yeah yeah that is a good thing and a bad
thing because it's a bad thing because
there are no rule so people can [ __ ] you
and take more of your money than they
are anyway it's a good thing that there
are no rules in America because you
could pursue whatever dream you want
there's nothing stopping you there's no
like family tradition and honor that you
have to uphold so you think there are
too many rules and Amaya's yeah I mean
compared to like a place like [ __ ] Amala
but also they can't drink I mean we have
rules like police are here you can't
murder people about that but we have no
rules in terms of you can smoke whatever
drug you want you can marry whoever you
want you can do whatever business you
want you don't have to rely on tradition
or worry about upsetting the old guard
like it's it's not true because the old
guard is very strong in America but it's
the appearance of that and the fact that
you can bring it up in conversation and
win arguments so I think that's what's
great about America is that we have the
appearance of life of having a
meritocracy yeah to do that yeah and not
every country is like that a lot of
countries aren't like Korea is just like
like a like a theme park for Koreans
like that's fine scraper
in downtown Seoul that's just like the
Science Building for the Korean
government it's like alien planet really
and this is like the headquarters for
the race of Koreans
have you been to Japan many sides yes
yes
what like how do they compare Japan I
think Japan is I think it's the richer
and I don't know they seem to have more
confidence in themselves even though
they lost World War two yeah all right
and they got then comes to make it yeah
yeah maybe it's a but barely so I mean
that's another [ __ ] more together the
Japanese like get [ __ ] yeah everything
is so clean and beautiful there yeah and
there's so I've seen like videos of
their subways and just how efficient
they are like it's you know the opposite
it's like how a society should be run
yeah if everyone's cooperating but if
everyone's cooperating you don't get
geniuses and rush artists
everyone's too busy
I'll have like people murdering each
other like we do it
that's the only way to create great art
don't look at ABBA yeah one Scandinavia
they got everything they still created
amazing music yeah
I mean I don't know I don't know how
much of this suffering is necessary and
how much we told ourselves that it is
I think a lot of it is unnecessary we
should be able to
I agree that
I definitely feel like I would drink a
lot
you would have to rely on the government
to be a source of self-discipline I know
yes
that was late
New Orleans are like Miami you can just
like walk around with your [ __ ] mojito
or margarita or whatever the [ __ ] it is
you drink razzmatazz
maybe it is I don't know everything
every toxicity respect you can walk
around with all that is cocktail special
foods yeah anything and like you know
you can even like take your razzmatazz
from the circus-themed dive bar and take
it to go and walk in to a different bar
do they exchanged cups at the end of
every week yeah they do have just lived
like Chico cops yeah yeah you can't I
think the rules like you can't have
glass on the street because like
understandably that would be problematic
you know
but yeah like plastic yeah yeah
I think that's Larry David or Bernie
Sanders who are these people said ariana
grande probably Ruth Bader Ginsburg
cardi B Oprah Tyrion Lannister
Cersei Ariana Grande Donald Trump Drake
Drake tone Bell I have no idea are you
proud of that joke Jesus I read this
could be you that's like a blank slate
that's me oh I see they can make you yes
Lady gaga good at it they're pretty
thick so maybe 25
yes I had a friend business the other
day and
he like we walk past this bar - I was
like happy at 6000 years and he was like
my god happy hour curse is six dollars
and I don't know any different like I
turned 21 here so I'm used to overpaying
for grades and I was like yeah what's up
twice about you and he's like normally
with three dollars and what are they for
happy hour yeah did you imagine that's
the price you pay for living in the
greatest city in the world will ever be
or ever has been so is it worth it
I say yeah I say yes as well yeah I
don't drink
I'm assimilated
yeah that's a that's weak that was one
of the like part of the reason I wanted
to get a flushing yesterday because I
was like I want to like eat like
authentic food but I don't want to play
over $6 that friggin thing that I should
have used the
the rice noodle ball big-ass plane was
more dollars [ __ ] yeah yeah in Manhattan
that would be like 11 even like Xi'an
famous foods just like $12 about $13
yeah we should I mean all you have to do
is take the subway sit on it
and then if you go to somewhere where
the prices are reasonable you know I
took the bus watching why did you do
that
I just president was easier then hey I
would have had to take like three cranes
to do like I get on the bus she walks
from my house and it goes directly just
less hassle yeah but it takes longer
yeah I love the Train I love the idea of
it I feel efficient on it definitely I
feel efficient on the bus too but not as
much because you have to still drive it
yeah and the bus is like a lot of times
you can walk faster yeah like in
Manhattan you're better off walking
honestly that's crazy one time I was
like driving for a job and I had to
drive from I was like driving in from
Queens so like strong
like 57th and wait first I was going all
the way to nine but just straight across
57th Street it struck like 45 minutes I
could have walked it in less time it's
traffic but if it's like snowy or it's
too hot then I like taking the bus just
do this more bus people [ __ ] on the bus
all the time smells like homeless people
suction on the bus now think cuz you
said you [ __ ] on the bus people [ __ ] on
the bus the viewers are missing out but
it's part of the experience in New York
misery tragic yeah so you will love the
bus and people [ __ ] on the bus but you
are in favor of the bus
I like the bus the bus it's fun the bus
is fun honestly because it's like the
Train
I find pretty depressing sometimes
because you're like packed in
underground you know it's a dark
soulless tunnel at least for my bus you
can see outside
it's people connected to the city yeah
[Music]
when you're like sitting there waiting
too long and they can feel people
getting agitated
they'll place a assaulting a bus
operator
it's topia
famous car
it was nearly face
it's not as cool as I thought it was so
this neighborhood used to be like the
home of the punch scene back in the 80s
and all those other places
and now it's just like celebrities
vacation homes and NYU students it's
pretty popular it's like a good place to
hang out
my Agra yeah you sponsor spot it's
probably the best place bet it's village
is a little it's too pricey and yeah
yeah a little petty
here's away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's going to visit his wife because she
go to the kitchen hi sweetheart